[MUSIC PLAYING]
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Hello,
and welcome to the Security
Zone at Google Next.
We're here with Andy, a
leading expert at Google
in security operations
and monitoring.
Thanks for joining us, Andy.
ANDY CHANG: Thank you.
It's great to be here.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
So we've all seen
that security attacks are a big
challenge for companies today.
If I'm running a security
operations and monitoring team
and I'm responsible for
managing these threats,
this is going to be an
increasingly difficult job
for me, right?
ANDY CHANG: That's
exactly right.
Security and operations
monitoring teams
always have new
threats to worry about,
so they have to
constantly be improving
how these threats are identified
and how they're remediated.
So let's take a look at a
few of the common scenarios
that a security
operations and monitoring
team needs to be able to
understand and remediate.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Great.
ANDY CHANG: The first scenario
we're going to look at
is these threats
from your employees.
So let's take a
look at an example.
Let's say one of your employees
is about to leave the company
and kickstart their new job.
They've decided to share
sensitive information
from their corporate account
to their personal account.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Oh, dear.
And that is a problem.
ANDY CHANG: Absolutely.
This would result in
potentially sensitive files
being leaked to the
public or to competitors.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So how can
my team identify and remediate
an attack like this?
ANDY CHANG: Well
let's take a look
at a view from our security
operations and monitoring team.
Here we see G Suite
Security Center
that has seen a huge spike
in the external file sharing.
So now your team knows that
there is something suspicious
going on, and they need to do
some further investigation.
There are hundreds of
employees sharing files
all over the company.
One of the first
things you need to do
is identify which one is
causing the huge spike
in external sharing.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So we
need to figure out who
is sharing all of this data.
ANDY CHANG: Right.
So if we go back to the
G Suite Security Center
and open up that
report, here you
can see that one employee,
Julie, has by far the most
sharing activity.
The first thing we
want to do, then,
is to understand
what she's sharing,
and if these shouldn't be
shared outside the organization.
And if so, then cut
off Julie's access
to these files from her
personal account immediately.
So again, back to
the Security Center.
We can go open Julie's
file sharing details
and see all the files
she has enabled access to
from her personal account.
We can switch off all of
her access to these files.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Wow.
That was fast.
So if Julie is trying to access
or download these files right
now, she won't be able
to because her access has
been revoked.
ANDY CHANG: Exactly.
The immediate threat
now has been stopped,
but we need to go one step
further and prevent these leaks
from happening again.
We can choose to prevent
individual users, groups
of users, or the
whole organization
from sharing sensitive files
externally like this again.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Got it.
So there may be a subset
of users at the company
that we want to stop from
leaking files like this.
ANDY CHANG: Yes, that's right.
If we took a look again
at G Suite Security
Center and the
Security Health screen,
we can see that there's
a recommendation
to remove drive external
sharing access to employees.
I can easily go in
and turn that off.
And now we've
remediated the situation
for the whole organization.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Wow, so we
were able to quickly identify
the threat, remediate
it, and then we
adapted security
controls to prevent it
from ever happening again.
ANDY CHANG: Right.
So as a security
and operations team,
tools like G Suite
Security Center
can give you the ability to
quickly identify, remediate,
and prevent these types of
employee insider attacks.
So that's how your team can
protect against employee
insider attacks, but
another potential threat
you may need to
be concerned about
is possible data access
from your cloud provider's
employees.
And to address that
concern, Google
has introduced access
transparency, which
is unique to Google
Cloud Platform
and provides an audit trail of
actions taken by Google support
and engineering, where they
interact with your data
and the system configurations
on Google Cloud.
So let's walk through a
scenario that shows off
access transparency.
So say that one
of your employees
is having problems
accessing some of the files
and needs to call
Google support.
Once that employee is speaking
to a Google support agent,
the employee walks
through the problem,
and to fix the problem,
the Google support agent
needs to access some of the
customer's system settings.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
So at this point,
an employee at our
cloud provider,
Google, needs access to
some of the system data
to diagnose the problem?
ANDY CHANG: Right.
So as a security operations
and monitoring team,
you want to be aware of
how the cloud provider's
employees access your systems.
So let's take a look at the
Google support agent's view.
To diagnose the problem,
the support agent
needs to access a
particular system,
but before they can
get that access,
they must enter a justification
for the additional access.
Before they can access
any of the systems data,
they need to log this
request detailing
why they need the access.
So now the Google
support agent is
able to access a limited
set of your system settings
in order to diagnose
the employee's problem.
The support agent is then able
to help your employee solve
the problem.
So on the Google Cloud
Platform, let's take a look
at the Security Command Center.
We can see that the support
agent's access request
has been logged after
they've entered it.
If we open up that
record, you team
now has transparency into how
the cloud provider's employees,
like the support agent,
are accessing your systems.
Here we can see
accesses to the systems,
when, what they accessed,
and the support agent's
justification for
the access requests.
So now your team can
monitor this access,
help ensure that your cloud
provider's employees are
interacting with your data
and systems appropriately.
So that's two examples
of insider threats, first
from your own employees
and second from the cloud
providers employees.
Another common scenario
your team has to worry about
is external threats.
Let's say you have systems
with varying levels of data
sensitivity.
In Google Cloud
Platform, we enable
you to programmatically classify
the data in your system using
our DLP API.
By understanding the level
of the sensitive data
within each project, we're
able to proactively assess
our attack surface and
potential blast radius.
Now let's say an attacker was
able to attack your systems
and compromise one
of your machines.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So this
is an external attacker
who has made a targeted attack
against one of our systems?
ANDY CHANG: Right.
So now that this machine
has been compromised,
your team needs to
identify this problem,
and based on the blast
radius of the attack,
understand the impact
of the incident.
In the Cloud Security
Command Center,
you can see how we
surface anomalies
that have been detected,
and identify the compromised
machine.
Using machine
learning, Google Cloud
is able to identify unique
patterns across systems
and can trigger detections for
your team in the Cloud Security
Command Center.
And you can drill down
here and see the details
of the compromised machine.
Now the attacker's access
to the compromised system
can be shut off, and
the blast radius impact
can be determined by calculating
the sensitive data compromised
across the effected machines.
With the Google Cloud
Security Command Center,
your team can quickly
identify and remediate
these external attacks
on your systems
and calculate the
impact of the attack.
So that's how your team
can protect against insider
threats and external threats.
But another challenge
that security teams
have to worry about
is how they can
integrate different security
tools across the company.
Most security teams
are using a lot
of different tools for
things like advanced threat
and endpoint security,
advanced network security, DDoS
and firewall protection,
and configuration security
and compliance.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So if
our team is managing
a whole group of
security tools, we
need to make sure that they're
all talking to each other.
ANDY CHANG: Right.
Otherwise your team might
miss some security threats
because security threats
are being managed
in too many systems and
places that don't communicate
with each other.
Google Cloud partners with many
of the top security companies
in the world to make
it easy to integrate
their solutions in the Cloud
Security Command Center.
For example, one partner
that Google Cloud partners
with for advanced threat
protection and endpoint
security is CrowdStrike.
CrowdStrike provides
advanced malware detection
and advanced endpoint
protection capabilities
to help your team
identify threats fast.
In the Cloud Security
Command Center,
CrowdStrike data can be
exposed as a new card
so your security team can easily
see these threats and actions
on them from one place.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So if
there's an error detected
in CrowdStrike, our team can
see it in the Cloud Security
Command Center?
ANDY CHANG: Right.
And clicking into
the card takes you
straight into the Cloud Security
Command Center's Findings
Inventory page, pre-filtered for
just the CrowdStrike results.
This is where we surface key
properties of the findings that
were provided by CrowdStrike.
Your team can then
explore the finding
by clicking into
its detail page,
and if your team wants to
investigate in more depth,
they can click on the link back
to the CrowdStrike console.
Google partners closely
with top security partners
to make integration between
these tools and the Cloud
Security Command Center easy,
and enables your team to unify,
index, and search across
all your finding sources.
Here we can add new cards to
connect with partners like Palo
Alto Networks, like CrowdStrike,
like Cloudflare, like RedLock,
to help you have a holistic
view of your attack
surface and your security.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So now my team
can identify and action threats
for all these applications using
just Cloud Security Command
Center?
ANDY CHANG: Right.
So your team can now get the
most out of all your security
tools, manage them
all in one place.
Google Cloud has a growing
ecosystem of security partners
that we are working
closely with to make sure
that our customers have
access to the best tools,
and quickly identify
and remediate actions.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So
with Google Cloud,
I can manage insider threats,
cloud provider threats,
external threats, and
I can integrate it
into the rest of my
security tools, right?
ANDY CHANG: Right.
With Google Cloud and the
Security Command Center,
your team can
manage these threats
and work to constantly
improve security controls
as these attacks get
more sophisticated.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Andy,
thanks so much for walking me
through how to manage a
modern security operations
and monitoring team.
ANDY CHANG: I'm happy to do
it, and thanks for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]